Speaker 1: So things continue to really just
go horribly wrong for Facebook.
We talked yesterday about the Monday outage
of Facebook, Instagram and WhatsApp.
We talked about the Sunday unveiling of who
is this whistleblower that released thousands
of documents about face internal Facebook
documents about Facebook knows about the harm
that's caused to different people by its platforms.
Frances Hogan, the name of the whistleblower.
And I played yesterday for you an interview
with one Facebook executive on NPR.
And it was just terrible.
Just the guys seemed shaken by the obvious
questions, unable to answer in a coherent
way.
Yesterday, we had testimony from the whistleblower
Frances Hogan, and then afterwards we had
a very unusual interview with Facebook's vice
president for content policy, Monika Bickert
on CNN, where again, I don't know if these
interviews go horribly wrong because the people
are unprepared or because the facts simply
aren't on their side, and there's really no
way to come off looking even remotely coherent
and sensible.
So first, let's start with a CNN article just
quickly outlining the takeaways from yesterday's
testimony by the Facebook whistleblower.
Francis Hogan yesterday testified before a
Senate subcommittee.
The big takeaways OK?
Facebook's mechanics further the spread of
misinformation.
One big takeaway second takeaway.
Facebook has taken limited action to address
existing misinformation.
We really knew this, but again, further confirmed.
Facebook has misled the public about the negative
effects of its platforms on children and teens,
especially young girls.
Despite public statements from Mark Zuckerberg
and others saying it's pretty good.
In short, internal documents show they know
about the negative effects, and Facebook knows
its platform enables human exploitation.
So let's get to this interview that took place.
This is an interview with Monica Becher, VP
for content policy on Facebook, and it's very
similar to the one yesterday that I played
for you from NPR.
Here we have video and it's deflections and
just kind of like strange, not very credible
denials
Speaker 5: is a current Facebook executive.
Monika Bickert is a Vice President for content
policy at Facebook.
Miss Becker.
Thank you so much for being here.
I really appreciate it.
I know you just heard that report.
And so I want to get your take on what Frances
Hogan has said.
Is it true that Facebook uses these algorithms
that push inflammatory content because that
drives more clicks and engagement?
It is not true.
And I want to say I think there have been
a lot of mischaracterizations today about
what those stolen documents say and about
the work that we are doing to keep Facebook
safe.
I just so I'm clear just I just want to be
clear,
Speaker 1: this is a key interjection.
What what specifically are you denying would
do not use?
Speaker 5: You're saying what part is not
true?
You don't push out inflammatory, controversial
content because, you know, that heightens
engagement.
We do the opposite, in fact.
Speaker 1: No, no.
Now that's just now is where it gets silly.
You push out non engaging content.
Come on, come on it.
It now gets, you know, I think, a better way
to answer this would be to say, unfortunately,
in our world, the most salacious news is more
likely to be shared by users, by users.
This is human nature.
It's not unique to Facebook.
I say I sound like a flunky now for, you know,
a PR person for these companies.
This is not unique to Facebook.
We can't control the fact that a lot of the
stuff that's most salacious that people want
to share is fake news and disinformation.
What we can do, however, is have an algorithm
that will no one label it as such.
And number two, not OK.
But no, no, we do the opposite.
But you push out stuff people don't find interesting.
Come on.
Speaker 5: If you look in our transparency
center, you can actually see that we did most,
meaning we reduced the visibility of engagement
based clickbait.
And why would we do that?
One big reason is because for the long term
health of our services, we want people to
have a good experience.
We want them to want to continue to come back
to these sites and connect with the people
they care about.
Speaker 1: What gets people coming back to
the site is that it's a source of titillating,
rage inducing, fear inducing material.
That's what keeps people coming back.
It would be Facebook doesn't think, you know,
if we keep doing this for 100 years, then
no, no.
It's just it doesn't work that way
Speaker 5: for years to come.
But my background?
Hold on.
I have a question about that.
Do you deny that teenage girls are not having
a good experience on Instagram?
The majority of young people on Instagram
are having a good experience, and that is
borne out by the documents that were stolen,
including the Instagram youth survey of about
40 Instagram users
Speaker 1: guys, 40 users, 44 zero on a platform
that has hundreds of millions is are there
billions of people on Instagram?
Speaker 5: These were teens who were already
struggling with mental health issues and on
all of the issues.
The majority of boys and girls said that Instagram
either makes things better or doesn't have
a material impact on their experience.
So hold on, hold on.
I just want to be clear yours.
Hold on just one thing.
I'd let you say your piece.
You're saying that you do not have internal
research that shows that depression and suicidal
thoughts go up for teenage girls, as do thoughts
of eating disorders.
I'm saying that for the majority of teens,
Speaker 1: that's really slippery.
The question is, do you have internal data
that says it's it's hurting young kids, including
girls?
What Monika Bickert says is we have one survey
that says it's not hurting them and it's based
on 40 people because what's the truth?
The truth is they have this 40 person survey
that they're pointing to, and then they have
all of the other data.
That is exactly what Frances Hogan said, but
she's not talking about that.
It's not.
It's not a denial.
It's just we also have this 40 person survey.
That's fine.
Speaker 5: Instagram and the survey that that
the stolen survey that was shared in the testimony
shows that the majority of teens, this was
a very small survey.
This is not peer reviewed research, right?
But that survey has been mischaracterized
significantly because of what it actually
says.
And we published it and people can look at
it for themselves on the 12 issues for these
teens who are already struggling with mental
health issues.
Instagram The majority of them said Instagram
either makes things better or it doesn't have
a material.
Speaker 1: How about so again now?
Now we're multiple minutes into a 40 person
survey, which is the only one she wants to
talk about.
Speaker 5: Now I know how about the minority
that 13 percent thought that said that it
increased suicidal thoughts.
It's important for me to say that I spent
my career as a criminal prosecutor and worked
a lot on child safety.
So even one teenager having a bad experience
on Instagram.
Speaker 1: So that's sort of an appeal to
authority fallacy in a sense, kind of genetic
fallacy that may have been what she was doing
in her previous role.
That's not what she's doing now
Speaker 5: is too many, and I can tell you
that the hundreds of people at Facebook who
actually do work on child safety, this former
employee did not, did not.
But those who do work on child safety and
work with dozens of external academics and
child safety experts say this is our top priority
as not
Speaker 1: who would who would possibly believe
that.
So there's there's a few more minutes to this
interview.
I encourage you to check it out.
You know, in a sense, it's genuinely surprising
how poorly prepared these Facebook folks seem
to be at the same time.
Maybe this is prepared as you can be, but
the facts aren't on your side, and that's
fundamentally what the problem is here.
So let me know your thoughts.
I know Facebook has to do something.
There's sort of these folks are, in a sense,
in an impossible position because they have
to defend the indefensible.
But this is not I don't believe this issue
is going away
any time soon.